how do you feel on those days when you
have no time to work on your writing
I get really depressed I get depressed I
get self-defeating you know I've always
believed in some weird way that I'm you
know the parable about the tortoise and
the hare kind of a thing you know I feel
like I'm like the tortoise kind of and
so I have a kind of really really strong
and present work ethic that sometimes
gets really annoying you know so I have
a really bad guilty kind of conscience
about not working so there are certainly
days where I not doing any writing or
not doing any kind of you know work
shopping and and it's frustrating
because you feel like you haven't been
productive but I think going back to a
bigger kind of frame I think those
moments are important you know when I do
experience writer's block and I go and
go for a hike and zone out and I spend a
day at the beach where I'm watching a
movie or something
I think a lot of good can come from that
you know gives you perspective and
distance from the project a little bit
and I also think that if you're not
writing it you know either because
there's something wrong with the script
with the story or that something else is
supposed to happen that you have to tend
to whether it's life things or whether
it's whatever so I try not to beat
myself up too much about it but but I
can be very hard on myself for sure
really sure it's interesting I see that
you would be more easy on yourself you
know I mean what we are I think in this
business so many of us were we're not
treated as business owners we're not
treated as entrepreneurs we treated as
struggling artists right but we are
business owners right we
are running our own business with
limited staff with you know high
overhead with trying to figure out how
to make our product different from our
competitors and we're all struggling to
find funding right and so we have to
kind of wear that hat with a little more
pride you know we are business owners
we're entrepreneurs and so it's it's
it's it's it is tough when you are
running your own business and you feel
like you know you're not going to work
on that one day and you feel like no
know what's going on so um you know I
think it's I think it's I think it's
tough when I feel like I'm not being
productive do you do you recognize that
when you're in the moment of it like
look suppose you have a week coming up
where you're really not going to have
time to work on your own stuff yeah and
you know that and you're like okay I'm
going to just have to bite the bullet
and do what I have to do but do you
start to recognize it in yourself like
oh gosh you know what it is it's because
I'm not working on my creative stuff
yeah you know I've read a lot of kind of
blogs and watched a lot of interviews
about other writers who either have the
luxury to write every single day you
know because they're they're being paid
to write a certain script or that's how
they work but and I I think for me I'm
not sure that I'm the kind of writer who
writes every day you know maybe I need
to be a little bit better about that I'm
not sure but I try to be mindful of what
is inspiring to me at the moment you
know and letting that energy build up
you know so that I'm not just sitting at
a computer like staring at a blank page
you know for me I think sometimes it's
important to stare at a blank page and
other times it's really important to
just kind of like let that energy build
up and build up and build up so that you
have a lot to say you know so that you
have a lot to say and a lot to express
and you can put it on the page and I
think that's important too
you